okay guys
i am testing this again
[Music]
oh wait i need you to talking with mike
testing
testing testing testing
that sounds better i think hold on
okay but there is
it's like four okay let me see if i get
rid of the bug knight
it is
let me see if i can
um
oh this one i forgot
all right testing testing
see
right
oh wait maybe that worked hold up
i know which one is it
okay so
it's not
what is that noise
it's one of the mics doing it i'm trying
to figure out which one
[Music]
[Music]
oh try that
oh shoot hold up put this
up here
[Music]
because
it's one of them causing it
put that over there and see if that
helps
oh yeah i think that might be it
let's see
oh wait two of them are muted
okay so it's one of these two
so
okay so it's mic number
three
so it's this mic
is it possibly that it's not all the way
oh no is this the one that fell off
did you hear what kylie named your
[ __ ] baby wolf
kylie jenner yes wolf
wolf
what the what's wrong with like
[Music]
liked norris and chicago to be honest
[Music]
stormy either
it's weird that kind of used to stormy
yeah but like i don't know i just don't
like it like it sounds like a stripper
name
yeah
so does northwest
oh my goodness
um okay
so it's my number three i'm going to see
if it's maybe the cord start with that
and see if that helps
um
okay we're going to try this
okay this is like okay it's okay okay
the person that commented on your tick
tock proving my point yes if you get
bored after an hour watching an amazing
show my seven-year-old is better than
you this is the thing we're adults and
if we want to leave we have the freedom
to do so because we're adults i only
reply to those because for some reason
conflict needs more views
i don't actually care okay let me listen
to this audio
um
like why do people literally nothing
better do their lives
[Music]
okay
oh my
god i think
oh my god
okay guys is there a buzzing still let
me know in the comments
i tried seeing if maybe it's the cord
that was the problem
so i switched out that cord and switched
it for a red one
um
putin has decided to invade next week
we're a little too close for comfort
how far they're from here let's look at
that ukraine
um
ukraine is me a thousand miles i'm 1
35 miles away
but like they're there we're here
they said that kylie would fall within
hours
what their capital would fall within
hours of an invasion is the u.s gonna
like protect them and they're just like
good luck with that bro no nato's they
have an alliance with ukraine so
yeah but like
i don't think
i don't know i can't i don't know enough
but
i don't know anything about foreign
policy
um
okay guys how's the audio like
i have a guy coming one day to like
fix it for sure but
she made me thinking i could do
oh my god world war three is gonna
happen
this is how it always starts
um i'm like uh i can't be i can't be a
which we'll call it the master
compressor
oh it's a touch screen
that's so cool yeah this is a great
soundboard i just don't know how to use
it
um we can hear you loud and clear if
that's what you mean
um
oh i need to order headphones
because i don't have headphones that can
like plug into this
um
um
what is it called when it's not like an
aux like it's the other type of
headphone
with it's flat like wireless headphones
no like a thicker one um
it's like it plugs into a different type
of cord i feel like someone in this
comment section might know
headphones
is
some of the comments says putin won't do
[ __ ]
i hope that he doesn't
i'm not going to worry about it till i
have to
i think these will work
oh my god 50 pounds i'm so tired of
spending money
huh
tortilla says i can contact her with
technical questions i did i just sent
her a voice memo
oh my god
[Music]
no not in the catholic
someone said is it okay to not have sex
before marriage would do everything else
and they asked that to a religious
person i'm like no like
i mean like we all do it anyway
so you know whatever but record by the
bible
no
we
you know my my grandfather
he didn't take communion for like
how long was it like seven years they go
to church like three times a week he
didn't take communion for seven years
because he had to get a vasectomy
and he felt so guilty about it he
refused to take communion oh my god
because my nona had such awful
um
like she almost died giving birth to my
uncle
like they would have had a bunch more
kids but they couldn't like with all of
her complications and so he had to get a
vasectomy for like her health
for her health and like you know birth
control was like yeah and yeah he did
take me in for seven years until a
priest like he did um confession or
whatever how did he just go to
confession right away
because he felt like he didn't deserve
to be like oh really yes like he could
have gotten that over with like
a lot quicker than that
so sad though it broke my heart when i
heard that first time
that is really sad
okay foam walls
oh
so
catholic guilt is another level man oh
my god it totally is
i felt guilty every time i had sex for a
long time
i swear to god like every single person
i slept with i felt really guilty
i don't know my family is like like i
grew up going to church a lot but then
like like
we don't go anymore so it's kind of just
like my my parents aren't super
religious
my grandparents
looks cool
i feel like also like
growing up i would i went to
um like bible school like i'm not like
my i didn't go to like a bible school
but i had bible school after school but
i'm saying growing up and like i just
never paid attention
well even if i didn't pay attention
nothing i didn't retain any information
i don't remember anything
so i need to okay i got scared i was
like i need to
tie these someone reminded me in the
comments
[Music]
i don't know i think because i wanted to
wait till i was married for a long time
that is why i felt guilty because that
was what i wanted to
those
do
were never had with me
[Music]
yeah it was
they weren't really had with me either
but they had them at our school so it
was very much like they
no you know what they did at our school
was in middle school they showed us like
a
slideshow of like
um just people that had stds like
that were just like really like
like just crazy photos that were just
super
graphic to like scare you out of like
doing things
and it was terrifying bro i get to see
like
like this is what it looks like this is
why i don't like this
like do stuff because i get scared
[ __ ] slideshow didn't work because i
had a girl when i was in middle school
who was a
year below me in the seventh grade got
pregnant
oh wow
we've never had pregnant girls like we
had one girl that was a pathological
liar that said she was pregnant but
yeah but like was she
she didn't come back to the school that
year but
i had a girl in high school so that was
literally one girl high school was
pregnant but her and her brother
precious
i'm trying to think what i was doing i
did have a girl in my high school that
um
was sleeping with the science teacher
and he got arrested but
she
they ended up getting married
basically once he got out of here then
and she was of age they got married
and we also had uh my theater teacher he
got arrested for having sexual relations
with students
this is why i don't believe in sex ed
i swear to god i i don't i don't believe
in sex side but it's not for the reason
people think it's not because i don't
think it should be educated it's because
i do not want a stranger teaching my
kids about sex what if it's like
a woman and it's like oh my god teaching
my son nope nope i've seen women do the
same [ __ ] it's like kids are gonna not
have sex like you know what i'm saying
oh i agree i'd just rather like be in
charge of it myself
like i'd rather have those conversations
with my family
yeah a stranger oh no
no i don't feel like parents even be
more open with their children and like
have those conversations with their
children themselves
yeah like i feel that way at least
i'm curious so this is like one okay
you're like
three i want to say you're
oh let's see this one is
underwear
guys okay i'm gonna i'm gonna turn hers
up i think
no talk
no i don't know but i just wanna see
can you guys hear gabby okay over there
when we were just having that
conversation
i just turned her volume up can you hear
it at least i think i did
hello
um
is
is
interesting i'm gonna try
putting three of these oh no i'm like
one so i can mine needs to go down
because i think guys i'm louder than her
i think
so which
isn't what exactly we want because
i kind of want to be at similar audio
levels but i want the other three to be
like
um
oh who's louder me am i way louder
you're saying
or me
well you just um
whispered why or are you saying that i
turned the mic louder
um
[Music]
audio processing noise gate you are
louder than she is yeah
i think i need to turn about my
threshold maybe
higher
i don't know what attack means
am i quieter now
what's the coop
i sound sad okay
did not help
okay testing testing
fantastic testing
[Music]
i mean you can always just wait to do
that
yeah that's true
like
you don't have to do it all at once you
know rome was not built in a day your
podcast will be built over time
that's true you'll make money off of it
if you just
like it's an investment yeah but like
you know
make some money out of it before you uh
yeah exactly
sounds like you'll need a man to help
yes
yes
we do
you do oh my
like you god understand all the stuff my
brothers would be helping me right now
or my dad but i'm in the uk
by myself
[Music]
so what time you have to be there doctor
oh my gosh and leave cyprus at 7 30 in
the morning
i'm not sure you want me to play
you can
oh my god
um
i don't know what
what
what
i don't know it's nothing else
i'm scared
all this soup that i've had
so far living here has been awful
soup yeah i've never had like good soup
here
which is unfortunate because i love soup
does gaby like the average height man no
i'm not gonna give my opinions any
longer
i don't want to be hated by the
manosphere
and i don't want to be
a
hated uh
person hated woman
atmosphere
[Music]
that means i can't give my opinions
i think
oh yeah in the nanosphere the ideal
woman is like
i'm never gonna be that yeah
i'm not
they like they don't like um
they want you to like sit down
and shout basically
like i'm italian i don't know how to do
that
i'm like
the ideal is like it's like a housewife
basically again that i can be a
housewife but like yeah but she got
i don't like tattoos
well [ __ ]
[ __ ] my tattoos are [ __ ] awesome
they always actually men don't like
tattoos but certain men do that's what
they don't the men i like do
it's a certain market um
man i don't think either of you still
struggle when it comes to love i
struggle all the time
wrong
favorite part
[Music]
i do pretty well in the web department
you do
yeah but i think
because i picked the weak ones i'm just
kidding
i pray on the week
so they're called beta guys
women are to be seen not to be heard yet
see yeah no
you
got me [ __ ] up
you want to hear me roar [ __ ]
no you know what men are to be seen and
not to be [ __ ] heard men need to
exactly why i shouldn't be on this
podcast
[Music]
right now
i love men i just hate a lot of them i
like good men
yeah my version of good i'm
so should i just stay angry
keep pissing me off
oh you sound good actually um
oh
just curious if this is gonna be better
if i use this mic
okay
um
also feel free to send some donations
help you girl out
there like
i'm working hard
she is
she's really working hard trying to get
her to go out tomorrow night and she
might not because she's work with
respect but
you know i just ordered headphones
65 y'all are killing me
okay you heard her send her 65
so she get some
headphones okay wait guys how does this
sound
this mic
do you guys prefer
because if i might mute out i'm muting
out the first mic i want to see if it's
less echoey the sound
because i may just start with three mics
and just have three people or four and
share a mic
so i may just start with three bikes and
just have three people or forwards
oh you hear much better this sounds
that sounds great
i think i need to just order a fourth
one of these
um i live stream two and run tests when
i change configurations no echo now
i just can't get this one but there's a
guy coming on monday so i think he might
figure that out for me
um some girl i put it on my
instagram story that i needed a man that
can do this audio stuff and her
boyfriend i said i could pay him to come
is that the one that
never mind
it's um it was just a girl that follows
me on instagram and she like isn't she's
in music she's like followed me for a
while
and i've like dm'd her a couple times
nice yeah and she just
said her boyfriend does that stuff
um
said i can pay him to come dig it look
at i'm excited guys
you know how much time i've spent trying
to get this [ __ ] to work it's not easy
um
okay
all right i'm ending this live stream
hopefully i'm trying to get this podcast
going
and like
if i get this audio [ __ ] running like
two weeks maybe that would be ideal
a week and a half that's what i'm
shooting for
so thanks for watching
send donations porfor